hello everyone this next game was played
in 1883 and it's played between Joseph
Henry Blackburn and the Williamstown is
the first world champion and okay
welcome Janice wasn't the world champion
when this game was played he won the
title three years after this game was
played but a lot of people consider him
to be the world champion even even long
before he won his title and a couple of
words about Joseph Henry Blackburn he's
a very funny if funny and a peculiar guy
well he actually learned to play chess
when he was 18 years old he played
dropped when he was younger
checkers see if you will and he only
learned to play chess because he heard
of Paul Morphy and his great conquering
of Europe and well he decided to pick up
chess and three years after he learned
how to play chess he entered a very
strong tournament the London the London
chess tournament in 1862 and although he
won ninth place
he actually defeated to go home Chinese
but this game is the place in some some
years after that event and let's see
this game so Joseph Henry Blackburn is
white and he plays efore strannix plays
e5 we have the Knight to f3 knight c6
Knight to c3 and Steines plays G 6-9 is
defense we have D for each Tetris and e4
Knight captures on d4 and Bishop to g5
to g7 attacking that knife so we have
Bishop to e3 we have an iOS 6 and now
Bishop to e2 where science castles we
have castles as well and now nice to e7
Bishop to f3 and this bishops I have
three as a well I'm sure most we would
probably play f4 here but Bishop Devery
is also an idea so we have these six
back Chinese and now Queen to d2 a
modern idea simply going for Bishop h6
and and to exchange this strong dark
square Bishop that Stein is put on g7 so
we have a knight Knight to d7 a bishop
to h6
nice to e5 and now Bishop captures na on
g7 King captures on g7 and now Bishop
back to e2 he doesn't want radius from Y
squared bishop for the night we have f6
back Chinese and now F for keeping the
night
for me five night to at 7:00 rook a to
d1 and now C 6 and Blackburn plays a
Bishop to c4 so we have a Bishop to d7
and this is where Blackburn really goes
for the attack and I don't think I would
even consider playing a move like this
but you'll see what I mean
he plays Bishop faster than f7 now
giving up this well very strong Bishop
for this night on f7 chinax plays rook
captures an s7 and now he pushes f5 and
well he doesn't really shine is not
really want to capture this pawn with
with his Jeep on because well Blackman
would even consider capturing with the
rook and you know understanding scans
part with this Bishop because this 936
check would be would be an idea and
shinies doesn't want to allow this he
plays Knight to c8 and this gives a
librarian idea for for improving the
attack he plays ePHI we have s captures
on e5 and now nice a e6 check now for
King the king and queen so the knight
has to be captured
we have Bishop captures only six F
captures on e6 now attacking this rook
and the Stannis doesn't want to capture
an f1 because this rook captures an f1
then disruptor seven check will be
really strong
so we have the rook to e7 and now
Blackburn plays Queen to g5 a very nice
idea this phone can be captured because
it's been nothing is defending standard
screen and e8 so we have a queen to e8
and now attacking this pawn twice
understand I mean a black baron cannot
defend this e6 pawn but he doesn't even
have to he plays rook to d3 a very nice
rook lift preparing truck to h3 so times
capture the pawn rook captures only six
and now Rupp to h3 we have Queen to e7
Stannis wants to exchange Queens of
course but now black plays Queen to a6
check and the shinies plays King to g8
not so so he doesn't fall out rook their
fates check but this is actually on top
of a black one place we're up to f8
check and the King has nowhere to go
only movies Queen captures an F face and
now Queen
captures on 87 with checkmate and yeah a
very nice game and a special against
someone who will very soon become the
world champion this is chicken 18:27
moves where chantix plays his own
invention - Steinman's defense and yeah
like I said in the title they call this
guy the Black Death
after after he defeated Chinese in that
first tournament and well I don't know
why they called him the Black Death
I mean okay his last name is Blackburn
so it might have had something to do
with that but I really haven't found any
any clues of why they called him that
I'm interested if if maybe some of you
know why they called him that and what
do you think of the nickname I think
it's extremely badass I mean I wouldn't
mind being called the Black Death when
you know playing chess so yeah there's
the game I hope you enjoyed this
wonderful wonderful game by Joseph Henry
Blackburn the Black Death again soon to
be world champion with sunshine it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here and all season